[Music]
Felicio vikander is showing her own body
confidence in the new tomb raider the
Vogue cover girl did some intense
workouts to get lara croft cut and i was
with the trainer who made it happen
I wanted her to be a strong physical
girl so I started to gain muscle and
gain strength how much muscle did Alisha
put on I think she gained 12 pounds
really yeah and was that all muscle yeah
I know what you're thinking at about
five five and 117 pounds alyssa is a
tiny woman to begin with
I started 3 months before shoot to work
with Magnus this film is about her
becoming the action here that we know
her to be Tomb Raider actually tells the
origin story of Angelina Jolie's Lara
Croft back in 2002 Angie did weight
training and Taekwondo to prepare for
the role her end result was this and you
can see alyssia's results too and let's
start all the way down so I tried out
the Magnus method at cross bootcamp
lots of intervals to burn off the fat
pull ups planks and twists for the ABS
thing is this not only worked for Alyssa
from Britney Spears to Alexander
Skarsgard on set for Tarzan Magnus has
helped whip other stars into shape I'm
going to list a few names and give me a
fun fact about you training them Katy
Perry smart Alexander Skarsgard beast oh
he's a beast in the gym at least yeah
is she a beast in the gym - oh yes
you